I love that it says stress-free scallops
I don't know about you but I'm stressed
this Suvi thing is not as easy as it
looks this video is sponsored by
lifestyle they've been one of my great
partners in 2019
now it's 2020 they're ready to start the
new year with a new year's resolution to
eat healthy and I thought what better
way to do that than to cook a meal with
you guys I know you really enjoyed it
when I did it last time now I got this
fancy new tool kit here it's a sous-vide
cooker basically cooking without a flame
in water with a ziplock bag I've never
done it before I'm honestly a little bit
nervous about it but huge thank you to
life some for sponsoring this video it's
my go to nutrition app tracks my
calories my macros especially when I'm
doing these 30-day diets I need a good
tracker jump into my description box
download the app for free or if you want
the premium version there's a link there
as well with the code dr. Mike 30 that's
going to give you 30% off the 12-month
subscription no-brainer got to do it
it's the new year new resolutions time
to become an educated consumer all right
I'm gonna scan all of these using my
life some app right now to figure out
exactly how many calories are in this
meal and what the breakdown of the
macros are remember macros are carbs
proteins and fats I'm gonna be cooking a
scallop meal with scampi and this angel
hair magic zero calorie pasta that I'm
really excited about scanning the
barcodes of the carrots
boom scanned scallops boom two
tablespoons of butter it's for the sauce
okay it's the sauce then we got this
zero calorie pasta wine blend of seconds
lay down my dinner got 31 grams of
protein 600 calories 33 grams of carbs
37 grams of fat a good mix of saturated
and unsaturated fat 700 milligrams of
sodium 1100 milligrams of potassium I
think it's a solid meal let's get
started look at this thing I feel like
it looks like a lightsaber even bears
excited you see bears a little face
creepy and fill a pot with water put the
thing in the pot plug her in and that's
it hmm I guess I have to get this app in
order for it to work
god I gotta create an account you know
what they say about a pot watching a pot
fill a watch pot
phil's where's that boils so for this
sous-vide cooking it actually is a slow
way of cooking so you keep the desired
temperature for a long period of time
that way you don't have to cook with an
open flame when you expose meat to a
fire you actually create some harmful
chemicals and when you cook inside a
lower temperature for an extended period
of time like this it's safer okay I
think that's how you do it
ideally you want to use a freezer type
bag those generally don't have BPA in
them and they won't leak plastic into
your foods
look at those scallops I'm gonna take
some lemon bear I have sharp object and
I'm gonna squeeze a little lemon into
here before so they marinate a little
bit and while I'm sooo beating yeah get
all lemon up throw that in there the
instructions call for a 40-minute cook
time in a 125 degree Fahrenheit okay I'm
about to click start
okay get cooking whoa that's cool why am
I so excited by that
while that whole cooking process is
going on here I thought I would start on
a the pasta as well as a scampi sauce
cool water I don't know if this is the
way to rinse boiling water probably
needs about two more minutes so I
probably should get my pan ready not my
pan whatever you want to call this
little thing what do you call it this is
a saucepan I'm gonna get this saucepan
melt butter in a saute pan
it's a saute pan I'm tired of working
with amateurs melt butter in a saute pan
over medium heat add olive oil raise
heat to medium heat I know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna try and be strategic
I'm going to turn off the boiling water
for a second because I want everything
done at the same time at the same time
boiling water put on hold for a second
melt butter and then how much butter the
answer is four tablespoons but we're not
crazy so I'll probably do a little bit
less than that four tablespoons equal a
cool
of a cup but then there's these sort of
dashes on it which one of these dashes
like if I just cut here is out a
tablespoon 1 stick equals 1/2 a cup
right so I need a quarter of a cup which
is half the stick okay okay
where's my knife isn't a butter knife
used for butter yeah good dad
god this looks like a lot of butter
maybe I won't use a Swiss sauce maybe
this is like for a family of four I
don't know if you're supposed to do it
this much but I feel like the more I
stir the better result I'm getting an
olive oil two tablespoons and raise heat
to medium-high there we got one
tablespoon in there second tablespoon in
there oh you hear that little scampi add
garlic and cook until fragrant for at
least one minute okay do you just put in
garlic like this or do you chop it up
and mince it it says 4 cloves this is
definitely not the way you do this but
you know what it's working and my
sinuses are getting cleared out I'm
gonna bring this to my oh yeah boy add
white wine and lemon zest and juice we
need 1/2 a cup of white wine right 1/2 a
cup I'm not making that up ok and they
set 1/4 cup of lemon juice this is
definitely not scientific and this is
definitely not a quarter oh no there's a
there's a seed ok wait don't panic but
the sauce I am panicking I'm starting to
panic dad where are these seeds coming
from oh it actually smells pretty good
that's similar until the sauce has
reduced in half but they also said add
parsley with no explanation of how much
parsley so I'm just gonna throw in some
parsley
barson I don't know how much parsley is
good I just seasoning with salt and
freshly ground black pepper how does
this work
does anyone know how this works I think
barely anything is coming out okay
I saw something happen black pepper it's
most okay but it doesn't look what do
you think about the appetizing nature of
this I thought it would be creamier is
it scampi supposed to be creamy okay I
have about 25 minutes on the sous-vide
cooking my scallops here my water is
about to boil so let's throw my weird
noodles into the water
what do I have to do to speed up boiling
what I heard like if you add salt it
boils faster oh boy yeah would you say
it's a boil I see a few bubbles so I'm
gonna go ahead and put it in a non oiled
pan to dry off god I feel like such a
chef cool sorry you didn't see that all
righty this is a big portion of these
noodles excuse me lemons mmm yeah look
at that garlic mmm it's totally not
supposed to be this water he looks like
a puddle Oh carrots let's get some
carrots in here for color you want a
nutritionally balanced meal and the
beauty about carrots is you don't have
to cook them I have to do it okay go get
the carrot
I love that it says stress-free scallops
I don't know about you but I'm stressed
I'm stressed just watching you I am
about done cooking masculine in my sous
vide you see it shooting I'm gonna stop
it and five four three two one
stop sous vide that's pretty cool
now I'm time to empty the scallops into
my dish don't judge me for this hurry
here you've everyone laughing in the
background
hold on I'm gonna spill some of the
sauce out based on my life some
calculations this is a healthy meal but
let's see how I cooked it
it's heavy on 11 if I was serve this in
a restaurant I'd send it back in soup
well because I made it and I know is may
love I'm enjoying it a little bit even
bear wants it he's our supporter
dan come in come in for a bite come in
for a bite 10 being the best the best
meal of your life zero being rat poison
there's a taste in there yeah it's not
that like I'm pulling your leg all right
so what's the number three I got a three
from the dan dan has no idea what he's
talking about solid six seven probably a
four in all seriousness I'm not a master
chef I'm just learning I tried the
sous-vide thing for the first time and
it's it's actually pretty easy like the
scallops were the best part the sauce is
where I failed
feels like my first time making sauce
you got to give me that we got all the
calories and macros for you courtesy of
Life sub it's the go-to nutrition app
they sponsor this video links down below
for the free download or 30% off your
premium version for 12 months it's a
no-brainer huge thanks to live some for
sponsoring this video hope you enjoyed
cooking with me and I want to do more of
these I want to get better at cooking
man like I'm tired of doing these sauces
and Dan telling me I'm a three I made
some cooking videos before and if you
haven't seen them here's a playlist
right here
I'll watch those with you you know being
happy and healthy
[Music]